you know the other night make up a month
ago not the other night a month ago the
lineup was me you Ali Wong Steve Byrne
on the same lineup so it wasn't an Asian
night he was sold out like a great calm
other what comments were on but we were
like in the meat of the show the lineup
and that fourth ask ask any comic that
were it was Asian like Jackson Perdue of
course yeah yeah he's great
back in the 90s and there's no way that
would have happened back then or yeah no
no no this was the first and also kind
of a very casual not big deal it wasn't
an Asian show we just happen to be there
and I mean it's so great and Ali is so
fantastic and so funny and it's such a
funny funny lineup yeah you know really
really awesome yeah they're not they're
all in their own way strong comics right
they're not like you know back in the
80s I'm not gonna name names but I know
that there were regulars at the store
that were Asian they would just put them
up just because of the color of their
skin because they want to try to
diversify the lineup but the person
sucked sucked yeah I know that I want to
but I'm not going to we will not and
this was not that this was people that
were like oh no these are the best
people that called in yeah these are
great cops
yeah yeah it's amazing it's really
amazing yeah but that other stuff
hopefully hopefully it changes I think
so I think that also people will look at
what you're doing in like what Ali's
doing and it ignites a whole nother
generation of people who are very
excited about comedy and they want to go
into comedy they don't want to think
about acting they want not thinking
about anything else they're just one of
these damn economy that's really cool
yeah I do every once in a while
how we'll have an Asian kid go you know
I'm doing it because you know I saw you
whatever yeah and you go really yeah but
it's great it yeah it is you know a
reality you know I'm not getting my head
out of proportion
what do you mean I'm not getting Eagle
right now what did I give you a look no
I just don't want I don't want she
doesn't like one of me well you know
what me won't you know me well Nia yeah
Nia yeah when I'm like he thinks when he
has moments where he thinks he's a
Korean Elvis no but everyone's well
sometimes I'm in Koreatown Yeah right
you know you know man shut your name oh
and then I'll give her wings like if I
take some photos I'll give her your
always killing it but you're better than
Elvis oh thank you yes
[Music]